on va passer tout de suite aux invités
du jour est-ce que vous vous souvenez de
Lucile cette jeune femme C influenceuse
qui était venue nous voir sur notre
plateau pour témoigner de l'harcèlement
qu'elle subissait depuis 2 ans un homme
la l'arcèle la suit la menace même de la
tuer malgré plusieurs plaintes l'homme
se trouvait toujours en liberté mercredi
soir Lucy a été agressé au couteau alors
qu'elle était avec un ami la peur au
ventere c'est elle qui va devoir encore
déménager petit récap et Lucy et
armignho proche de luici qui a été
blessé le soir de l'agression seront
avec nous pour nous raconter encore
cette histoire complètement rambolesque
[Musique]
merci dès 2021 Lucile une jeune
influenceuse d'une vingtaine d'années se
retrouve harcelé et menacé de mort sur
les réseaux sociaux par un individu je
vais tout faire pour te retrouver
d'accord donc fais pas la excédéestiment
laisser pour compte la jeune femme qui
vivait alors un véritable calvaire était
venu il y a quelques mois sur notre
plateau crier son désarroi j'ai
l'impression d'être tout le temps en
Caval alors que c'est pas à moi de fuir
c'est pas à moi de changer de pays mais
alors que luil avait été contrainte de
déménager plus d'une fois pour pour se
mettre à l'abri elle vient de partager
une terrible nouvelle sur les réseaux
sociaux affirmant avoir été agressé au
couteau avec son ami et déclare
désormais vivre dans la peur je ne me
sens vraiment plus en sécurité et
déménager ne change plus rien alors
harcelé poursuivi depuis plus de 2 ans
Lucile a été attaqué au couteau elle
témoigne avec son ami blessé ce soir
dans
TPMP pas merci Lucile merci armino
d'être avec nous merci beaucoup on va
nous dire ce on va vous dire ce qui
s'est passé il y a un instant carmminho
merci en tout cas d'être là tu harcelé
suivi tu reçois des messages de menace
pourtant rien ne se passe depuis 2 ans
lucide c'est un truc de ouf qui t'arrive
et cette semaine tu as échappé au pire
puis qu'un homme t'a agressé toi et ton
ami chez toi dans tes escaliers
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé euh de base
j'étais chez moi donc j'étais avec un
ami et mon ami est descendu pour c'est
c'est Aminous non j'étais avec un autre
ami aussi en fait qui est parti qui
partait donc il il prend son uber et il
me dit il y a un livreur en bas qui m'a
dit qu'il avait une commande duberit
pour toi sauf que j'avais rien commandé
donc je lui dis c'est bizarre j'ai rien
commandé je lui demande de me faire une
description et là il me fait la
description et ça ressemble à quelqu'un
que je connais donc je lui demande de
revenir et d'essayer de parler avec la
personne ou de prendre en photo la
personne pour que je puisse avoir des
preuves que cette personne est venue
chez moi il revient il parle avec et je
lui dis qu'il est sûrement armé et donc
ensuite je les entends parler dans mes
escaliers donc cette personne est a
réussi à rentrer dans mon immeuble donc
avec le code et cetera connaissait ma
porte et en fait quand il est venu quand
mon ami est revenu cette personne
m'attendait dans les les escaliers donc
dans les escaliers il attendait que je
sorte de chez moi pour pouvoir peut-être
m'agresser et ensuite du coup ils sont
descendus par aller en bas et là arminho
est arrivé et du coup il s'est passé
quoi alors moi je suis arrivé et bah
j'ai vu l'ami de Lucile qui était tout
seu en bas dans dans l'entrée du hall
parce que avant de rentrer dans dans son
bâtiment il y a il y a un il a comment
s'appelle SAS ouais un sorte de SAS et
du coup je suis rentré dans le sas et je
vois l'ami de Lucile et je dit bah
qu'est-ce que tu fais là tout seul et
ensuite je regarde à gauche et puis là
je vois un profil bah ouais tu étais
tout seul toi euh oui j'étais tout seul
donc je vois un profil que que j'ai
reconnu et je lui ai demandé bah
qu'est-ce que tu fais là genre qu'est-ce
que tu fais là et euh bah l'ami Lucile
il a directement commencé à dire il a un
couteau il a un couteau donc ça veut
dire qu'il a commencé à sortir son
couteau et de là bah je l'ai je l'ai
attrapé je l'ai je l'ai fait une
soumission et euh bah il a il a réussi à
sortir son couteau pendant la soumission
et du coup il a commencé à mettre des
coup de couteau coup de couteau et du
coup ça me faisait mal donc j'ai
commencé à reculer et pendant que je
reculais bah il essayé de me planter
planter planter donc ça veut dire il a
essayé de me poignarder à plusieurs
reprises et je me suis pas rendu compte
mais à un moment donné il a réussi à me
mettre bah du coup il a réussi à me
poignarder sur le bras et euh bah
ensuite j'ai appelé des gens et j'ai
fini par crier parce que j'allais arrivé
à une sorte d'impass donc ça veut dire
que ça allait être le moment où soit
j'allais mourir ou je sais pas ou alors
ce que je voudrais savoir est-ce qu'on
se pose on se pose tous la question
c'est que euh depuis tu es victime de
harcèlement depuis plusieurs années
puisque tu as porté plainte contre un
homme euh qui est allé en prison qui est
ressorti on pas rappelé l'histoire oui
oui c'est un homme qui a harcelé Lucile
qui a été condamné plusieurs fois et la
dernière fois on en a parlé ça nous
avait sidéré c'est qu'il a été relaxé en
mai 2023 par le tribunal de de Pontoise
parce qu'on avait pas pu lui attribuer
la paternité des messages d'insulte
qu'il vous envoyait et depuis on avait
plus de nouvelle et là vous êtes sûr
vous avez vous avez reconnu cet homme
vous vous êtes certains que c'est lui de
nouveau qui est venu vous
agresser c'est ça qu'on voudrait savoir
est-ce que c'est lui ou c'est pas lui
c'est un autre comment on peut savoir
que c'est lui bah j'ai pas trop le droit
d'en parler mais pourquoi bon bah parce
que je suis en procès avec lui
mais bah moi je l'ai reconnu quoi donc
c'est sans doute lui c'était sans doute
lui c'est ce qu'on a c'est ce qu'on a
plutôt compris vraable voilà non mais ce
serait fou ça veut dire que le mec il a
été condamné combien de fois par rapport
à luici euh au moins deux fois oui de
fois et une fois relaxé pour le troisème
procès que vous avez intenté et donc il
continue il va chez elle incroyable en
Chau déguisé donc en en chauffeur uber
nonou ou je voilà uberit et donc et et
derrière et derrière il se passe quoi
c'est ça qui c'est il continue il a pas
compris c'estàd qu'il avait été
miraculeusement relaxé il continue alors
je ne sais pas si depuis mai 2023 parce
qu'il avait interdiction de prendre
contact avec vous est-ce qu'il vous
avait envoyé de nouveau des messages ou
des menaces non il est pas rentré en
contact avec moi il avait déjà été
condamné deux fois par rapport à moi il
avait déjà été condamné aussi par
rapport à mon ami qu'il avait déjà
attrapé dans la rue et qu'il avait
menacé avec un couteau parce qu'il
pensait que j'allais arriver et aussi en
bah en mai 2023 je crois il avait essayé
de rentrer chez moi oui chez mes parents
et là il avait été il avait eu un rappel
à la loi et c'est ça que je comprends
pas en fait c'est pourquoi il faut
attendre que il ait attaqué mon ami avec
un couteau alors que tout le monde
savait que ça allait arriver dans tous
les cas et c'est ça qu'il faut attendre
pour que maintenant peut-être il a un
jugement et que peut-être il soit
condamné alors qu' il a déjà montré tous
les signes qu'il allait agir et ce qui
est fau c'est qu'il faut rappeler quand
même que c'est un monsieur que vous ne
conna
c'estd que il vous a vu sur les réseaux
il fait une fixette sur vous et vous
l'avez jamais rencontré dialoguer ou
échanger al actuelle je l'ai encore
jamais vu c'est ça qui est fou il est
obsédé par vous en fait il a développé
une obsession de vous qui va jusqu'à
agresser à coup de couteau vos amis ça
inroable vous avez déjà d'ailleurs
menacé avec un couteau regardez on a des
vidéos et des audios sur les réseaux
sociaux regardez sauteras mon adresse
apparemment et tu sais quoi regarde
regarde 50 kg mais moi je me bats pas
bien juste premet qu'essie de me sauter
c'est simple je le plante sa grand-mère
la reine maintenant attends juste juste
que tu reviennes de Corse on va voir
j'ai peur de personne va balance mon
adresse celle de mes parents même si tu
veux viens
ose venir mais ose venir je t'attends
mais je t'attends avec un plaisir déjà
rien qu'aujourd'hui aussi mais viens
maintenant tu sais où j'habite
viens alors il vous a aussi déjà envoyé
des vidéos de de lui rodant dans la
ville dans laquelle elle vous habitiez à
l'époque regardez je à la mairie de je
sais que tu habites ici mais si tu
habites pas dans une autre ville moi je
viendrai je vais venir je t'assure que
je vais venir et t'inquiète pas regarde
bien regarde bien je suis je sais que tu
je vais tout faire pour te retrouver
d'accord donc fais pas la moi je te le
conseille il porte pas plainte ça c'est
un conseil et c'est même un ordre que je
te dis d'accord alors il vous a laisser
aussi des des DM moi je m'en balc si je
mets le feu à ta FA out ta maison on va
tous finir à se fixer toi tu vas perdre
tout tu verras c'est moi je vais gagner
à la fin chaque jour je vais aller à sa
sortie jusqu'à ce que je je te l'attrape
toi tu crois tu changes de pays ça te
protège je vais m'attaquer à ton reuf
cette fois peu importe tu es où je je
bon voilà si tu continues à m'ignorer je
rentre dans ta fac ou je rentre chez toi
c'est juste parce que vous l'avez ignoré
à la base bah là c'est parce que je
l'ignore j'ai plus de nouvelles de lui
et toutes les il il m'envoyait plus de
message parce qu'il savait que sinon il
allait directement en prison donc je
savais que la prochaine étape c'était
qu'il viennne chez moi mais je sais pas
comment il a eu mon adresse étant donné
que mon adresse je la mets sur aucun
papier quand je vais porter plainte je
me domicilie toujours chez mon avocat je
la donne à personne je fais super
attention sur les réseaux sociaux je
montre jamais quand je suis dans ma
ville je montre jamais rien je montre
rien du tout donc je me demande comment
il a eu mon adresse et peut-être même
qu'il a le code de chez moi étant donné
qu'il a réussi à rentrer dans l'immeuble
et monter en une minute le temps que mon
ami parte donc ça aussi je me pose la
question incroyable mais oui j'ai je
comprends votre panique et votre
angoisse quand il a réapparu donc
visiblement mais est-ce que vous avez
appelé la police parce que vous dites
que vous avez rappelé votre copain pour
qu'il vienne voir si éventuellement
c'était lui ou pour qu'il discute et
tout votre premier réflex c'est pas ça
pas été d'appeler la police mais j'étais
pas sûr que c'était lui en fait pour moi
je me disais que c'était pas possible
qu'il a retrouvver mon adresse et du
coup mon ami est revenu en fait pendant
qu'il parlait dans l'escalier je voulais
pas appeler la police directement parce
que j'avais pas envie qu' qu'il m'entend
parler vu qu'il était derrière ma porte
et qui et qu'il metettent un coup de
couteau à mon ami ou quoi donc j'ai
envoyé des messages à ma mère et cetera
je lui demandé d'appeler la police pour
moi j'ai envoyé des messages à à mes
amis après dès qu' dès qu'ils sont
descendus en BL j'ai appelé la police
directement alors euh il avait déjà
agressé l'un de tes amis la suite de
cette agression il avait enfin été
condamné il a pris 8 mois fer mais il
n'a fait que 3 mois et une fois le
libéré il a recommencé à à te harceler
oui c'est ça alors tas déménagé combien
de fois j'ai déménagé deux fois deux
fois et là une trè fois donc là je vais
redéménager mais je pense plus rester en
France parce que ça sert à rien oui il a
toutes les caractéristiques d'un d'un
psychopathe quand je lis les messages et
quand je vois les messages qu'il vous a
envoyé vous savez à quoi ça m'a fait
penser ça m'a fait penser au message sur
telégram que le tueur de Prague euh
envoyait enfin ça a les mêmes
caractéristiques psychologiques donc
enfin je dis pas du tout ça pour vous
faire peur mais en fait je me dis
comment est-ce que c'est possible
qu'avec de tels indices sur une une
folie qui peut être une folie meurtrière
personne ne fasse rien ça ça me paraît
complè la première fois qu'il a eu la
prison et qu'il a fait de la prison
ferme il y avait pas d'injonction de
soin avec qui était assortie avec sa
peine il y en avait mais je suis pas
sûre qu'il les fasse pas fait mais il y
en a eu visiblement ça va pas mieux du
coupou j'ai vu une psychologue qui m'a
dit ça j'ai j'ai vu une psychologue qui
m'a dit que pour elle c'était un
psychopathe et qu'il allait pas arrêtter
tant qu'il avait pas tué quelqu'un alors
ce que la question que je poser les
téléspectateurs ils disent après ça il
est où là actuellement après l'agression
de vous avez de nouveau pter plainte oui
donc il va sûrement être de nouveau
entendu à chaque fois on va le dire très
franchement il est entendu parfois même
il a été poursuivi les sanctions sont ou
inexistantes ou clémentes et pour
retrouver Lucile il faut savoir qu'à un
moment il avait créé 40 pour la harceler
pour retrouver Lucile aujourd'hui qui
est protégé et c'est tout à fait normal
et c'est bien c'est que sans doute il a
des contacts très haut placés un certain
niveau pour avoir des adresses pas il y
avait pas une histoire comme ça on avait
évoqué une protection on avait évoqué
une protection alors on on on avait
évoqué le fait que pour avoir des
sanctions aussi faibles sans doute que
dans sa famille il y avait un lien avec
une autorité judiciaire ou quoi
l'histoire on avait dit oui on avait
voilà on avait dit quelqu'un de sa
famille était père policier ouendarme
ouais c'est ça son père était policier
ou gendarme c'est ça voilà après on nous
a demandé de de de rester vague aussi
par rapport aux enquêtes qui sont menées
et voilà cette personne on ne la nomme
jamais et c'est tout à fait normal c'est
aussi à la demande de de Lucile on ne
donne pas son nom voilà à la fin Cyril
moi je vais le dire c'est impossible que
quelque part cette personne ne soit pas
protégée voilà il faut le dire euh ici
on dit tout ça comment ça parce que
c'est incroyable de dire ça bah cy les
sanctions sont inexistantes il a du
surcil prob il recommence elle déménage
il la retrouve non mais ou ou mais non
mais la protéger sont
mais les sanctions sont il est rel quand
il a été relaxé donc voilà c'est c'est
tout à fait oui mais il y a pas de lien
entre la police et et les tribunaux ce
que je dis non non ce que je dis
n'engage que moi mais il échappe à
tellement de sanctions qu'à un moment on
se dit pourquoi cette personne est
encore en liberté aujourd'hui question
voilà moi je vous pose je pose la
question très
claireensible je vais te dire demain
n'importe qui euh
fa çaain qui est ministre de l'intérieur
c'est ministre de l'Intérieur il sera
pas protégé hein je te le dis donc voilà
donc je vois pas pourquoi lui et voilà
il connaî qui j'en sais rien mais à
chaque fois il échappe à tout Cyril il
il récidive à chaque fois il brave dès
qu'il est relaxé ou condamné faiblement
il fait des messages pour braver la
justice et pour dire je vais revenir je
vais te trouver je vais recommencer et
il la retrouve il recommence il est un
avocat il est un avocat j'imagine oui
bah il doit avoir un bon avocat non non
mais c'est mais a des avocats qui se
battent pour a des G comme là il y a une
tentative mine de rien d'homicide
sur monsieur disait que ou ça étéalifié
ça a été requalifié en violence volonire
non ah ouais ça a été recalifié en
violence volontaire avec un couteau oui
oui alors que la question que je me pose
c'est aussi un problème les
gars problème surtout si j'étais pas
là ça même toi quand il t'a planté il
savait pas où planta il auraiit pu te
tuer il aurait pu toucher vit voà pour
moi c'est tentative d'homic je suis
désolé là ça a été requalifié en
violence volontaireme non mais c'est me
mec problème il y a un énorme problème
quand il était entré chez
Lucile il avait réussi à être exonéré de
sanction parce qu'il était alcoolisé oui
c'est alors voilà normalement quand on
est alcoolisé c'est une circonstance
agravante circonstance agravante et lui
comme il était alcoolisé alors voilà oui
j'ai j'ai bu trop d'alcool j'aurais pas
dû faire ça
à chaque fois c'est ça non c'est fou h
moi j'hallucine avec ton de ton histoire
bah oui en plus là la question que je me
pose c'est s'il y avait pas mes amis
qu'est-ce qui me serait arrivé aussi
parce que il était dans mes escaliers il
m'attendait il m'attendait il
m'attendait à droite de ma porte j'avais
juste à ouvrir ma porte et puis c'était
fini et même il aurait pu tuer enfin il
aurait pu tuer arm bah oui c'est ça que
je ça que je pense aussi à arminho M tu
as pris combien de coup de couteau euh
j'en ai pris je pense une dizaine mais
je les en fait je faisais que de les
esquiver donc ça veut dire que il il me
touchait mais il mffleurit il y en a que
un seul qui m'a touché je me suis pas
rendu compte c'est dans le bras ouais
ouais ouais d'accord mais bon quand même
il en vrai s'il avait pu te planter il
l'aurait fait parce que j'ai crié je
pense à partir du moment où je me suis
dit là ça va être la mort je me suis mis
à crier il y a du monde qui qui est
arrivé il est parti en moi ce que je
comprends pas Lucile ils disent quoi tes
avocats parce que en vrai on hallucine
tous ici de ce qui se passe c'est'est
passé une fois deux fois trois fois le
mec on se dit mais y a un problème il y
a un problème là maintenant j'ai un
nouvel avocat après j'ai pas souhaité
assister au jugement parce que j'ai pas
envie d'y aller et de le voir je sais
pas ce qu'il peut penser dans sa tête
non plus mais vraiment la question que
je me pose c'est pourquoi il a pas été
condamné avant en fait c'est bien même
si maintenant oui c'est bien il va être
jugé c'est bien il a été arrêté et
cetera mais ça aurait dû être fait avant
il est où là il est où là il est en
garde vue ouais il est en garde vu là il
en garde vue d'accord mais là c'est une
tentative d'assassinat vous avez porté
plainte monsieur je suis ça arrivé quand
lu ça arrivé avanthier avanthier
d'accord avantier et là il est en garde
à vu oui après il va être jugé d'accord
et et oui la question que je me pose
c'est pourquoi rien n'a été fait avant
alors qu'il y a toutes les car enfin on
sait on savait tous que ça allait
arriver et ça aurait pu être pire oui on
le savait tous il y avait tous les trucs
il a il a essayé de venir chez moi il il
a bravé une interdiction de rentrer en
contact avec moi il est venu chez moi il
a pas respecté ses obligations il a une
obligation de de travailler ou j'en sais
rien il est il le fait pas il a des
obligations de soins il les fait pas
donc je comprends pas en fait qu'est-ce
qui a été attendu parce que là c'est
bien il il va peut-être il va sûrement
être condamné vu qu'il a quand même
attaqué avec couteau mais je pense pas
non plus que ce sera une une sanction
qui sera énorme tentative d'assassinat
c'est
becoup a mais je t'expque viol VI
volontaireite il va même pas rentrer
ilon vience volonire c'est même s c'est
incroable je histoire essayé as parlé
alors tu en a parlé ici ça ça médiatisé
l'affaire on en est heureux mais ils te
disent quoi même les aut aorité des
trucs bah de ils me le disent que enfin
ils disent pas grand-chose en fait te
disent de continuer à porter plainte oui
de continuer à porter plaines et
d'attendre bah que la justice fasse son
travail mais moi je suis enfin je suis
désolé mais la police fait le boulot
c'est la justice qui la police il l'ont
arrêté et cetera c'est la justice qu'
relâche à chaque fois alors qu'il y a
toutes les enfin il y a toutes les
preuves là il a fallu attendre que
quelqu'un se fasse planter et ça aurait
pu être pire on aurait pu on aurait pu
mourir et puis il dit à chaque fois
qu'il va reprendre ses oui il le dit
option luême disait au début il lu
disait moi la justice je m'en fiche peu
importe que je fais je suis dehors j'ai
déjà été condamné sort il remenace avec
fierté il dit de toute façon il va rien
m'arriver jeen ai rien à faire et même
dans dans ses auditions il il
regretteent pas du tout à chaque fois
non il brave il fait il ffaron il se
tarque de ne pas être condamné il
provoque il revient il fait preuve d'une
arrogance qui sidère tout le monde et à
chaque fois ça passe voilà donc c'est
cette affaire est incroyable est-ce que
c'était vous déjà qui l'avait menacéve
ah c'est vous déjà ah c'est vous il
avait menacé avec le couteau en 2021
c'était vous déjà là il vous avait juste
si je puis dire juste menacé ou déjà
frappé non il m'avait juste menacé avec
le couteau et du coup à ce moment-là
j'avais rien fait parce que c'est pour
ça que vous l'avez reconnu vraiment là
ok d'accord non mais c'est donc voilà
c'est toujours lui alors aujourd'hui
elle fait quoi ça pardon elle fait quoi
ben elle déménage elle F ah elle a déjà
déménagé deux fois elle va porter
plainte à chaque fois elle fait tout si
je puis dire bien voilà elle elle ne
répond jamais aux provocations aux
menaces elle est exemplaire dans sa
défense mais ça ne suffit pas et elle
est de nouveau menacé elle a raison de
médiatiser elle a raison de médiatiser
parce que ça peut peut-être faire Chû
vous êtes protégé ou pas vous avez
demandé une protection non et j'en ai
pas et pourquoi vous demandez pas une
protection policière à ce niveau-là vous
pouvez non mais tu vois c'est ça qui
raisonnement
c'est c'est normal ce que tu dis on va
payer quelqu'un qui la protège d'un
abruti qu'on sait même pas pourquoi il
le temps de l'instruction oui bah ça
fait déjà qu instructions on va mettre
des policiers qui ont sûrement autre
chose à foutreéger une demoiselle qui
faiter
bououp de Coutou il prend dans le bras
s' se déplace et toi tu veux mettre des
flics derre mais non c'est là que ça va
pas tu as raison mais ça va pas du tout
en fait moi ça va pas du tout pour moi
il a rien on sait même pas ce qu' ve
qu'est-ce qu'il veut en fait on sait
même pas qu'est-ce qu'il ve là je pense
que maintenant il est énervé parce qu'il
all en prison donc ah donc c'est sans
fin en
fait c'est un fou c'est un fou mais
qu'on aurait pas pu sair fou oui mais il
est très organisé il fait des filatures
pas possibles des repérag il doit avoir
des il doit avoir des information pour
mais c'est ça j'en suis sûr il a des
contacts quelque part pour vous
retrouver alors que vous vous cachez il
a il y a quelque chose il a je dis pas
des complicités mais il obtient des
informations qu'il ne devrait jamais
obtenir voilà ça vous êtes d'accord avec
ça il y a quelque chose qui qu' a fait
que il peut vous menacer en toute
impunité bah je sais pas comment il fait
pour trouver mon adresse en sachant que
je l'ai mis sur aucun papier et que je
fais super attention à tout ce que je
monre sur les réseaux sociaux je montre
j'ai jamais montré où j'habitais même
les alentours ou quoi je montre jamais
même compris compris les procédures les
procédures judiciaires et cetera ils ont
ils ont ils ont bien gommé votre adresse
et C il y a plus rien il y en a aucune
et mon adresse je ne la donne même pas à
la police je l'ai donné nulle part je je
me domicilie toujours chez mon avocat ou
alors au commissariat suffit qu' la pote
chez l'opérateur che qui chez qui vous
êtes il peut savoir où vous êtes
exactement à 10 m près donc il a pas mon
numéro non plus normalement normalement
ouais mais l'opérateur i vous allez
faire quoi alors vous allez redéménager
ah moi je pense que je vais quitter la
France parce que ça sert à rien à chaque
fois je déménage je déménage je déménage
et là je sais que je vais déménager même
s'il est condamné il va sortir je sais
pas peut-être dans 2 3 4 ans ce sera la
même chose il va revenir il va retrouver
mon adresse et c'est c'est s fin jusqu'à
ce qu'en fait je meurs donc ça sert à
rien que je reste ici maintenant moi
j'ai j'ai plus confiance je préfère
partir et faire ma vie mais là si on
fait rien c'est non assistance à
personne en danger he bien sû mais c'est
une histoire de fou merci merci j'père
que va aller mieuxon merci Luc ch